four more in the room and then we'll  turn to zoom  last row Center  hey Asia I saw that John quill kind of  walked across the court and came to hug  you uh character building for next year  it was setting something up  um Williams in the corner versus  somebody in the paint  um so we were able to yeah  fast but go ahead  um so our spacing just had to be  different but I had to be aggressive on  the ball first like I was a little  passive in game three trying to see and  scope scope it out going into the pick  and roll so I knew I had to be  aggressive thank  we're going to start with Doug from  Australia  uh we're on Zoom you can't see me  I'm part of that